foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
and we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to discuss some new
information about House of the dragon's
second season I believe this article was
released last week by variety however I
wasn't able to go over it with you until
now I think you will find this
information to be as interesting as I
did because it does give us a better
understanding of what new characters we
will see next season now before I show
you who HBO has added to their second
season of House of the Dragon let me
tell you about this amazing new offer
I'd like to thank the sponsor of today's
video brilliant now brilliant.org is an
Interactive Learning tool that uses a
Hands-On approach to teach you a wide
range of stem Concepts like math and
computer science brilliant has thousands
of lessons with new ones being added
every month you can exercise your brain
and reach your goals with everything
from foundational and advanced math to
neural network status science Ai and so
much more AI chat Bots and quantum
computers are advancing and playing
bigger roles in our lives all the time
and learning how they work is
fascinating it has been perfect for me
as a Hands-On learner because it tests
you along the way by offering
simulations to manipulate in quizzes to
further your understanding right now you
can try it for free for 30 days by
visiting brilliant.org talking Thrones
or clicking on the link in the
description brilliant is the best way to
learn something new every day and
learning a little every day can have a
huge impact on your brain's Health and
Longevity I like to spend 30 minutes on
brilliant in the morning while having my
coffee it's a much better way to
stimulate my brain and get ready for the
day than scrolling through social media
now the best part is you don't have to
spend a fortune or four years in a
classroom either like I said go to
brilliant.org Talking Thrones or click
the link in the description to check out
all brilliant has to offer it is free
for 30 days in the first 200 of you will
get 20 off Brilliance annual premium
subscription you don't want to miss out
on this amazing offer once again I have
to thank brilliant for sponsoring
today's video now let me show you what
variety revealed in their new article it
says some new faces are heading for
Westeros as HBO has revealed four new
actors are joining House of the dragon's
second season the actress Gail Rankin
will be our Alice Rivers who is known as
a Healer and resident of harrenhal an
Author George R Martin's novel Fire and
Blood On which house of the Dragon is
based Alice is a witch who has the
mystical visions and becomes a
significant figure within the
targaryen's green faction in fact we
should meet her near the beginning of
the new season when Damon arrives at
harrenhal I know I'm very interested in
seeing what house of the Dragon will do
with this character because she does
have some similarities to Maggie the
Frog and even Melisandre according to
amond one eye he says Alice Rivers is
able to see the future and her Visions I
am hoping we get to see this in the new
season I would love for the show to have
some more of the mystical magical and
mysterious elements that help make Game
of Thrones so great I know I always
loved watching and reading about the
characters who worked in the shadows of
the realm now another new actor HBO has
brought on for House of the dragon's
second season is Simon and Russell Beale
who will be our Sir Simon strong the
castellan of harrenhal and the great
uncle to Lord Lara strong once again
this is another new character we should
meet at the beginning of the season when
Damon arrives at Aaron Hall he will be
the one who actually surrenders
harrenhaal to Damon once he sees him
flying above on his Dragon caraxis
another new actor HBO has hired is
Freddie Foxx who will be our sir gawaine
Hightower the son of Otto Hightower and
Allison's brother we should see Serato
name his son as the second in command of
the city watching King's Landing at the
beginning of the new season Serato will
have his own son look over the city
watch as a way to make sure they're all
staying loyal to their new king aegon as
you all know there will be a lot of
backstabbing happening as everyone sets
their sights on the iron throne in last
but certainly not least HBO has hired
actor abubakar Saleem who will be our
Allen of Hall a sailor in the valerion
fleet who served in the battle of the
stepstones now in this new season when
it is decided by Jacari valerion during
the dance of the dragons that the blacks
need more Dragon Riders many met on
Dragonstone will attempt to ride dragons
including Dragon seeds such as Adam of
fall and his younger brother Alan we
should see Adam win over lane or
valerion's old Dragon sea smoke but it
will be interesting to see if that still
happens because we all know Lenor
valerion is still alive as you all know
dragons will not accept the new Rider
unless their old one is dead since we
all know Lenor is still alive I wonder
if we will see someone else ride his
dragon without him either way Adam of
fall isn't the only one who looks for a
dragon of his own his brother Alan will
also but it won't go so well Alan will
go for the wild Dragon sheep stealer
when he enters his lair in George's
novel Fire and Blood the dragon Set Fire
To His cloak his brother Adam had to
beat out the Flames while sea smoke
drove off sheep stealer now while Alan
was burned and scarred by The Experience
he counted himself fortunate to have
lived as other Dragon seeds and Seekers
who had aspired to ride Chief stealer
ended by being being eaten alive by him
instead so as you can see the four new
actors HBO hired should have significant
roles next season they won't only be
extra standing around in the back of the
room we should see all of them in the
mix interacting with the main characters
in the main story now the one I'm
interested in seeing the most is Alice
Rivers because like I said earlier I
love the ones who are shrouded in a bit
more mystery then again we will have to
wait and see what house of the dragon's
writers do with them because if you
remember George RR Martin did say the
second season will now follow Fire and
Blood word for word although I did give
you a good description of what they did
in Fire and Blood it doesn't mean we
will see them do the exact same thing in
the show let me know what you think
about these new additions down below who
are you looking forward to seeing the
most leave me some of your thoughts
about variety's recent article as always
I have to thank all of you for watching
my video I hope all of you have a great
day I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
foreign